20 ans l'âge de tous les possibles
dit-on souvent mais aujourd'hui c'est
aussi pour beaucoup un âge de grande
vulnérabilité la preuve à l'instant avec
ce documentaire exclusif réalisé par
Charlotte higuignoli l'avocat dès lors
comment mieux comprendre mieux prendre
en compte mieux accompagner cette
détresse psychologique qui gagne du
terrain chez celles et ceux qui traverse
pourtant ce qui est censé être la
période la plus insouciante de leur vie
nous allons en débattre maintenant sur
ce plateau de débat dooc avec vous pour
commencer Amandine Buffière bienvenue à
vous vous êtes pédopsychiatre et
présidente de la Fédération des Centres
médico psycho pédagogiques mélissa
tafati est également avec nous bienvenue
vous êtes étudiante en sciences
politique et peut-être surtout aussi
aujourd'hui bénévole de l'UNICEF et
cofondatrice du podcast Nomo avec
l'UNICEF justement et euh ce podcast est
consacré juste justement à la santé
mentale des jeunes vous êtes par
ailleurs cofondatrice du média colibri
et de son podcast time to talk dédié
cette fois à l'engagement associatif et
puis Flor gris est avec nous bienvenue
vous êtes étudiante sche-femme quelle
année je suis en 4e année de sche-femme
sur 5 ans d'études 4e année sur 5 ans
d'études pour être sche-femme
aujourd'hui exactement ouais vous êtes
aussi vice-présidente en charge de la
santé au sein de la FAGE qui est la
Fédération des associations
étudiante c'est donc la santé à votre
domaine en tant que vice-présidente de
la phage on va revoir si vous voulez
bien un tout petit extrait du
documentaire pour commencer notre
échange à propos des facteurs de stress
concernant bien entendu les jeunes la
caractéristique des étudiants par
rapport aux autres non étudiants c'est
le cumulle des facteurs de stress qui
arrivent sur ce temps des études et ces
facteurs de stress on les connaît ce
sont les facteurs académiques et
notamment la sélectivité ce sont les
facteurs culturels notamment pour les
étudiant sujetti à la mobilité que ça
soit cette mobilité nationale ou
internationale ce sont des facteurs
économiques la fameuse précarité
étudiante et enfin le moral des
étudiants va être impacté par
l'effondrement on l'a vu pendant le
covid de tel ou tel filière industrielle
c'est votre collègue psychiatre
Dominique monchablon qui s'exprimait
ainsi pour déterminer ce que peut-être
ce que peuvent être les les facteurs de
stress et de fragilité pour pour les
jeunes avec une conséquence directe hein
selon la santé publique France un jeûe
sur 5 un jeûe sur 5 aujourd'hui
souffrirait de troubles
dépressifs avec de plus en plus par
ailleurs de pensées suicides on l'a vu
hein dans ce documentaire pensé
suicidaire qui concernerait d'ailleurs
surtout les les jeunes femmes hein
plutôt que les les jeunes je homme c'est
ce que j'ai appris en en travaillant ce
dossier c'est ça l'état des lieux il est
bien défini par euh ce à la fois ce
documentaire que nous avons vu et cette
prise de parole de votre collègue oui
oui tout à fait il est il est bien
décrit en fait c'est c'est très clair
qu'il y a eu une accélération au moment
du covid mais que c'est c'est ces
troubles effectivement étaient présents
avant mais là ça y a vraiment une grosse
accélération alors sur le le les ID ce
qui m'a interpellé très sincèrement
c'est qu'effectivement euh
cette crise sanitaire a beaucoup pesé
hein sur la santé mentale des jeunes
c'est une évidence mais on a envie de
dire pas seulement mais on aurait pu
penser qu'après avoir passé cette cette
ce malheureux épisode les choses se
seraient amélioré or tous les
indicateurs montre qu'au contraire euh
la santé mentale des jeunes a continué
semble-t-il à se dégrader là j'aimerais
comprendre pourquoi ben alors c'est
difficile de le dire de manière très
scientifique mais en tout cas il y a
aussi d'autres éléments comme les les
craintes environ Environnmental le
climat quand même politique inquiétant
avec la guerre en Ukraine et puis
probablement d'autres choses mais c'est
vrai que c'est un moment quand même de
fragilité je pense pour toute la société
et qui pèse en particulier du coup sur
les étudiants qui sont au moment où ils
vont se projeter un peu dans la vie et
quand le la société le monde dans lequel
on se projette est très incertain je
pense que c'est particulièrement
difficile ouais pour pour les jeunes et
les étudiants c'est aussi la situ est un
peu la même pour les enfants les enfants
ont aussi vu une augmentation des des
troubles mentaux la difficulté à se
projeter dans l'avenir à se projeter
dans la vie c'est la conséquence de tout
cela vous venez vous venez de le dire
aujourd'hui les jeunes ont de plus en
plus de mal à se projeter dans l'avenir
quand on a 20 ans et ben il faut qu'on
leur demande mais je pense que oui c'est
un des éléments du
problème aujourd'hui alors on va leur
demander on va commencer par vous on a
bien défini les les les symptômes
d'après que les retours que vous pouvez
avoir vous de votre côté pourquoi est-ce
que la situation continue d'empirer même
si nous avons passé cette
violente épidémie avec toute ces
conséquences et toutes les conséquences
qu'on a
connu je pense que naturellement déjà
notre âge et la période de vie étudiante
c'est une période de très grande
instabilité parce que on se remet
beaucoup en question c'est une période
où d'un côté on doit construire notre
projet professionnel on doit exceller
dans le domaine dans nos études en fait
et de l'autre côté on dit qu'on doit
profiter de la vie profiter de ce si B
âge que que c'est les plus belles années
de notre vie donc on est pris un petit
peu dans cette entre deux et
parallèlement voilà il y a ces facteurs
de risque qui qui qui nous empêche un
petit peu de nous projeter parce que
c'est un moment où on doit nous on a
besoin de nous projeter dans l'avenir en
fait et et c'est vrai que ça ça pèse
beaucoup parce que ça crée beaucoup de
d'anxiété qui est lié toujours à au
futur ou au passé et donc on on on se
pose beaucoup de questions sur le futur
et et on a on a du mal à se projeter oui
parmi les facteurs identifiés dans
l'extrait que nous venons de voir il y a
l'accè au logement la mobilité
euh le facteur économique la précarité
étudiante la hausse des prix qui touche
et qui impacte forcément les budgets des
étudiants il y a une hiérarchie selon
vous parmi tous ces facteurs qu'est-ce
qui arrive en en priorité et qui
provoque l'angoisse des jeunes dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui euh je pense que
c'est la pression par rapport aux études
qui est très très importante après ça
dépend aussi de la situation de chacun
forcément il y en a qui sont qui ont
plus de moyens que d'autres tout ça mais
c'est vrai que la pression par rapport
aux études je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est très très important parce
que en fait on a l'impression maiselle
vient d'où cette pression c'est une
pression une pression parentale c'est
parcours su c'est cette sélectivité
justement dès la fin du secondaire
réellement qui qui provoque qui serait
selon vous au-dessus de la pile j'ai
l'impression que c'est vraiment un tout
mais et en même temps en fait on a
l'impression que c'est une pression qui
est très très normalisé par la société
par notre entourage par les professeurs
aussi qui avant même de commencer
l'année on nous dit ah c'est une année
qui va être très compliquée va vooir
vous accrocher mais c'est compliqué en
fait de de de d'avancer en se disant ça
en partant du principe que déjà on va
avoir du mal à à réussir je pense que là
il y a il y a un changement dans
l'université qui est en train de qui est
en train de s'opérer les étudi de le viv
en premier vous parliez d'hérarchie de
de cause et je pense que pas réussir à
savoir comment est-ce qu'on va finir le
mois pas réussir à à savoir comment
est-ce qu'on va se nourrir bah ça c'est
une source de stress est extrêmement
présente et la crise sanitaire elle a eu
aussi le fait de pas pouvoir se projeter
et le fait en fait de même pas pouvoir
se projeter sur la fin du mois ça entage
cet ge cvant ou à 20 ans en fait on se
projette dans notre vie et on doit se
projeter dans notre vie et si on n pas
la source financière et on n pas les les
conditions de vie qui permettent cette
projection là et ben en fait on se rend
compte qu'on a une santé mentale qui est
dégradée et on se retrouve avec des
étsantes en détresse psychologique et le
reportage le montre très bien en France
il y a un tiers de d'étudiants boursiers
environ il y a toujours les parents tout
de même he qui sont là pour aider le C
chant un certain nombre d'étudiants
euh et malgré tout la précarité gagne du
terrain la précarité étudiante nous on
le voit concrètement à la FAGE parce
qu'on on a des Agora c'est des épiceries
sociales et solidaires donc c'est des
épiceries où on vend des produits qui
sont à 10 ou à 20 % du prix du marché et
on en fait on se rend compte qu'il y a
énormément d'étes qui sont dans le
besoin qui vont dans ces épiceries là et
qui concrètement arrivent pas à manger
vous parlez de foyer familial nous la
vision qu'on a à la f c'est un étudiant
et une étudiante qui est émancipé sa
condition de vie donc dans la réforme
des bourses qu'on porte pour nous un
étudiant étudiante il devrait pas être
dépendant de ses conditions de vie et de
ses conditions familiales et donc pour
ça on porte une bourse pour tout
étudiant étudiante qui souhaiteraiit
bénéficier de cette bourse là et c'est
vraiment la vision qu'on a c'est cette
émancipation que ça soit dans les études
cette émancipation elle est aussi
nécessaire par le moyen financiers qu'
les étudiants étudiantes et donc oui les
bourses elles sont présentes mais
actuellement on se rend compte que c'est
pas suffisant et on se rend compre
concrètement avec la détresse dans
laquelle vivent ces étudiants étudiantes
là il y a encore bien trop de de
d'étudiants étudiantes qui renoncent à à
des repas qui renoncent à à des
constitutions de vie décente mais qui
aussi renonce à des soins et ça je pense
que ça le met bien en perspective par
rapport au reportage il y a presque
un/ers des étudiants étudiantes qui
renoncent à des soins pour des raisons
financières donc ça c'est quelque chose
de concret qu'on voit et en fait on se
rend compte que c'est encore plus un
public prioritaire par la santé mentale
dégradée de de ces étuds étudiantes sur
le la question des familles qui peuvent
soutenir les étudiants je pense que la
plupart des familles des étudiants
boursiers sont aussi des familles qui
traversent des difficultés et qui même
si elles le veulent ne peuvent pas
forcément soutenir les étudiants et
après c'est vrai que sur l'accès aux
soins euh je pense que les étudiants
sont une population qui ne peut pas
euh payer les soins enfin pour qui les
soins doivent être gratuit accessible
voilà et c'est vrai qu'il y a dans les
zones urbaines comme Paris euh consulter
des psychologues ou des des psychiatres
en privé en fait ça coûte très cher et
donc c'est pas accessible de fait au aux
étudiants on va y revenir he sur cette
problème de l'accompagnement hein qui
est central évidemment dans dans notre
sujet en revanche lorsqu'on dit que la
sélectivité h ce que vous avez dit joue
également un rôle très important dans la
charge mentale le stress ressenti par
les jeunes vous le ressentez aussi à
travers vos consultations oui tout à
fait je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est
quand même dans une société où quelque
part il y a un espèce d'impératif de
réussite scolaire universitaire
c'est-à-dire que on Nimagine pas qu'on
va pouvoir réussir sa vie si on n pas
fait d'études ce qui est à mon avis
assez nouveau par rapport à il y a
quelques années maintenant il y a je
sais pas combien 80 % ou 90 % d'une
classe d'âge qui accès qui qui qui
accède aux études supérieurs alors que
avant je pense qu'on il y avait quand
même davantage l'idée qu'on pouvait
réussir sa vie si on avait pas un master
et puis en plus il y a probablement une
inflation en plus c'est-à-dire qu'avant
avec une licence alors maintenant les
étudiants ont tout de suite en tête
qu'il faut des diplômes solides et même
avec des diplômes solides le le le monde
est tel que parfois même avec un diplôme
on est inqui moi j'ai une étudiante qui
est qui fait de des films d'animation et
là elle est en alternance et en fait
elle s'est rendu compte compte entre le
début de son alternance et maintenant
que l'intelligence artificielle va faire
80 % du travail que elle faisait au
début de son alternance donc en fait il
y a des changements tellement rapides
euh qui peuvent être un peu inquiétants
et et ça demande beaucoup de capacité
d'adaptation en fait aux étudiants alors
il y a un facteur qu'on n pas encore
évoqué celui des réseaux sociaux j'ai lu
ici ou là que l'émergence et la montée
en puissance et peu de le dire des de la
fréquentation des réseaux sociaux par la
génération dont on parle aujourd'hui
pourrait avoir des conséquences euh
psychologiques très négatives est-ce que
c'est votre avis également oui alors je
crois que c'est pas que pour les
étudiants je crois qu'il y a des études
qui montrent que la fréquentation des
réseaux sociaux est associée à une plus
grande incidence de de la dépression ou
de l'anxiété mais chez tout le monde et
particulièrement chez les étudiants
peut-être parce qu'il ils fréquentent
plus les réseaux sociaux enfin ils on
une plus grande euh c'est surtout
l'image que renvoi les les les les
réseaux sociaux pour leur utilisateurs
oui qui semble poser problème après il y
a effectivement cette idée dans les
réseaux sociaux euh enfin c'est le monde
est idéal c'est-à-dire que on est très
beau on réussit bien et on ne montre que
ça et donc ça c'est un gros souci qui
est de de ne montrer que le monde sous
sous un œil qui qui n'est pas la réalité
en fait donc et oui ça je pense que
c'est une pression surtout que vous
dites le 20 ans c'est le plus bel âge de
la vie je pense que c'est pas forcément
le plus bel âge de la vie et que
peut-être c'est important aussi qu'on
puisse dire ça aux étudiants c'est pas
le plus bel âge de la vie forcément pour
tout le monde m parfois c'est c'est
c'est d'autres moments et et c'est vrai
que les impératifs de réussite ouais
social je pense peuvent peser très lourd
et notamment à travers les réseaux
sociaux je vous voyais avoir envie de
réagir sur cette question des réseaux
sociaux c'est peut-être des remonté que
vous avez aussi vous oui ben c'est vrai
que sur les réseaux sociaux on a
tendance à montrer seulement ce qu'on a
envie de montrer en fait et on a pas
forcément envie de montrer les moments
où on n'est pas bien c'est ça les
moments de détresse en fait et aussi on
a tendance à beaucoup se comparer aux
autres comparer notre situation à nous à
celle des autres et ça crée aussi
parfois un sentiment de de de
d'illégitimité face à nos à nos
problèmes de santé mentale tout ça on
voit les autres on voit aussi des
situations qui sont parfois pires que
les nôtres et on se dit mais en fait je
suis pas légitime d'aller mal quand je
vois que par rapport à ma situation en
fait alors que c'est c'est c'est c'est
pas du tout le cas tout le monde est
légitime d'aller mal voilà ouais ça
alors c'est c'est très important parce
que il y a il y a des des gens qui
n'osent pas
aller vers les soins en disant en fait
j'ai pas de raison de me sentir mal en
fait psychiquement on n pas besoin
d'avoir une raison de de sentir mal pour
aller consulter ça je pense c'est un
message très important parce que les
gens disent mais voilà tout se passe
bien dans ma famille les études ça va et
pourtant je me sens mal alors alleer
consulter vous venez de le dire oui
c'est évidemment et et aller consulter
le plus tôt possible hein parce que
évidemment la santé psychologique plutôt
elle se dégrade et s'il n'y a pas
d'accompagnement bien évidemment
derrière ça a des conséquences tragiques
et ça peut aller jusqu'à des pensées
suicidaires on l'a très bien vu
d'ailleurs dans ce dans ce documentaire
et c'est quand même tout le problème
hein il y a un MRE de psychologu dans
les services de santé étudiants un
psychologue pour 15000 étudiants alors
là ce chiffre fait peur he c'est 10 fois
moins que la recommandation
internationale bon MRE de psychiatre en
France les effectifs ont diminué de
pédopsychiatre votre profession dont les
effectifs ont diminué d'un tiers en 12
ans hein pour passer de
de 3000 à à 2000 pédopsychiatre ça c'est
le problème numéro 1 c'est l'accès
l'accès à la consultation et à
l'accompagnement psychologique et j'ai
vu que la f se battait beaucoup sur ce
terrain oui c'est quelque chose qu'on a
on a beaucoup demandé et qu'on continue
à demander parce qu'actuellement il y a
le cheèque PSI qui donne accès à 8
séances gratuites pour les étudiants et
étudiantes sauf qu'en fait on se rend
compte que ça fait 2 ans que le
dispositif est mis en place il y a que 2
% des étudiants étudiantes qui qui en
ont bénéficié parce qu'en fait il y a en
fait c'est difficile d'accès peu
d'étudud connaissent même l'existence de
de ce chèque là et le fait de commencer
une prise en charge en disant que dans 8
séances ça sera fini et que l'ANT il
devra débourser de sa poche on a vu que
la précarité étudiante était un problème
majeur mais en fait ça coupe la
projection qu'un étudiant étudiante peut
faire dans dans cette prise en charge là
et donc nous la vision qu'on a du check
PSI c'est déjà augmenter la
communication autour pour que l'ensemble
des étud éudantes en ont connaissance et
et en fait enlever cette limite des h
che PS et que ça soit vraiment une
discussion qui soit faite avec le
thérapeute pour savoir combien de
séances sont nécessaires et et qu'en
fait cette prise en charge soit enfin
soit qui dure la durée dont l'ANT on a
besoin et qu' a pas une finalité qui
soit déjà inscrite avant même de
commencer ce parcours là alors
pardonnez-moi mais ce fameux chè PSI he
qui a eu assez peu de succès jusqu'à
maintenant on va essayer de comprendre
pourquoi mais enfin il a le mérite
d'exister parce qu'il était censé
pouvoir répondre à une urgence parce que
former un psychiatre ou un
pédopsychiatre peut-être ça prend 10 ans
tout de même hein c'est voilà le chef de
l'État d'ailleurs rappelait que il est
bien conscient du problème mais que pas
se faire en claquant des doigts
autrement dit ça ne répond pas à
l'urgence quant aux
psychologu sont-ils assez nombreux
visiblement pas pour la prise en charge
de ces de ces problèmes alors j'ai un
petit bémol là-dessus effectivement
former des psychiatres et des
pédopsychiatres c'est très long mais par
contre des psychologues aujourd'hui il y
en a pas mal en France il y même de plus
en plus oui et donc on on pourrait en
alors pourquoi il y en a si peu pour
s'occuper du cas des étudiants
aujourd'hui alors il y en a si peu mais
parce qu'il y a des moyens qui n'ont pas
été investis dans les structures de
soins publics comme moi je travaille
aussi dans un B pu bureau d'aide
psychologique universitaire qui sont des
équipes pluridisciplinaires pour qui
peuvent accueillir les étudiants
gratuitement et en fait il y a pas de
Bapu qui a été créé donc il y a une
quinzaine de Bapu c'està dire qu'il y a
même pas un Bapu par ville universitaire
et ils ont pas été enfin il y a pas eu
d'investissement dans les bapus et et le
chèque psy je pense ça ne marche pas
très bien pour la la raison que vous
avez évoqué c'est-à-dire que une
thérapie la fin de la thérapie ça doit
se décider entre le thérapeute et le
patient et pas quelque part parler état
qui dit en une séance ça doit être réglé
ouais et puis en plus c'est assez mal
rémunéré donc les psychologues ne s'y
retrouvent pas en fait dans au vu des
chiffres il y a peut-être un problème he
sur ce sujet parce que le site santepsi
étudiant recense
1187 psychologues qui auraient participé
qui seraient d'accord hein de participer
à ce fameux che psy et sur plus de
4000 psychologues existants aujourd'hui
en France là je me suis demandé tout
simplement si les psych jouit vraiment
le jeu de ce chy alors parce que c'est
pas assez rémunéré a où est le problème
là allez-y m ouais je pense que c'est
une très bonne initiative ce ce Chep
d'avoir des séances de psychologues qui
sont remboursé mais tout autour de cette
initiative est compliqué c'est-à-dire
que avant d'avoir accès à une
prescription de 8 ou 10 séances qui sont
remboursées il faut aller voir un
médecin généraliste et çaou médecin
traitant ou un médecin généralist ça
déjà c'est quelque chose qui peut
repousser parce que on n pas envie de
justifier pourquoi on envie d'aller
consulter un psychologue c'est pas
quelque chose qui se justifie on n pas
besoin d'avoir un trouble particulier
pour vouloir aller consulter un
psychologue ensuite c'est ça le le côté
des ou 10 séancesou enfin c'est c'est le
chemin qui est valable pour n'importe
quel adulte à priori hein vous donz
d'abordir votre médecin traitant qui
lui-même va vous prescrire peut-être et
vous conseiller d'aller d'aller
consulter un psychologue après pas dans
tous les cas parce que enfin je sais que
moi par exemple j'ai pris la décision
d'aller consulter un psychologue mais je
suis pas du tout passée par mon desin
traitant avant et euh j'ai juste pris
cette décision euh alors que j'avais pas
forcément de problème particulièrement
diagnostiqués et euh et euh est-ce que
vous conseillez par exemple dans votre
euh dans ce que vous faites avec ce
fameux podcast avec UNICEF d'aller
consulter ah oui totalement en fait nous
on on a envie vraiment de lever les
tabous qui existent autour de la santé
mentale et à les consulter c'est
vraiment un pas en avant vers
l'ouverture de de de ce tabou en fait
parce que ça euh ça ça ça permet de de
d'encourager les jeunes à à prendre
conscience de leurs problèmes à prendre
conscience que que qu'il faut en parler
de ces problèmes et c'est ça aussi il
faut vraiment ouvrir la parole sur le
sujet pour permettre de de d'avoir accès
à plus d'informations sur le sujet et de
réellement desestigmatiser ce sujet en
fait et je pense que concrètement on
avait on avait dit que oui la population
générale doit les consultants médecins
généraliste aussi pour avoir accès à un
thérapeute dans le cadre du dispositif s
qu'en fait on a vu que la précarité
étudiante était un frein d'accès au
soins de manière générale et donc en
fait on se rend compte que demander à un
étudiant ou une étudiante d'avancer une
séance chez un médecin généraliste en
fait c'est pas quelque chose qui peut
faire parce que ça va être ça ou des
repas et donc en fait concrètement quand
on a mangé ou aller consulter bah les il
fait vite son choix et donc c'est aussi
pour ça que même même si on lui dit que
il pourrait avec ce dispositif avoir au
moins vous l'avez dit 8 ou 10 séances
gratuites il aura h séances il saura
déjà déjà il faut aller voir un tierce
lui parler de ses problèmes ce qui est
déjà quelque chose de compliqué à déjà
effectivement une démarche compliquée
après il faudra l'avancer cette séance
parce que une séance un médecin
généraliste faut l'avancer c'est pour ça
qu'à la FAGE nous on demande un tiers
payant généralisé pour tous les étudants
étudiantes donc concrètement qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire que quand on va la
consulter on n pas besoin d'avancer les
frais parce qu'on est trop précare pour
le faire et on n pas les moyens
financiers pour avancer ces frais là et
après donc déjà là on est allé fait ces
deux démarches là et après faut aller
trouver un thérapeute et avec ce
thérapeute là on faut commencer un lien
commencer vraiment une prise en charge
et voir que dans 8 s ça sera fini voir
cette fin qui va arriver et qui va
approcher et en fait je pense que ça en
fait on devrait faire confiance autant
professionnel qu'X étud éudant pour
comprendre quels sont les besoins de
chacun chacune et adapter cette prise en
charge là adapter la durée de celle-ci
et alors je crois que la FAGE propose
une consultation gratuite oui auprès de
psychologue oui ça marche ça fonctionne
il y a beaucoup de candidats est-ce
qu'il y a beaucoup de psychologues qui
répondent présents à cette initiative de
la FAGE alors ça c'était un projet qu'on
a porté au niveau des des des
universités parce qu'en fait
historiquement on a porté le CH PSI
avant qu'il soit créé avant sa mise en
place donc c'était quelque chose qu'on
demandait et donc la f dans la
construction des projets qu'on a c'est
que face à l'inaction du gouvernement en
fait on décide de nous mettre mettre en
place qu'on demande au gouvernement de
le faire on voit avec les Agora et les
épiceries sociales et solidaires on voit
une précarité alimentaire donc on crée
des épiceries sociales et solidaire donc
là c un peu pareil on demandait un accès
au psychologues il y en avait pas donc
on créit ce dispositif là au niveau des
universités là actuellement il y a aussi
la réforme des service de santé
universitaire où on on a beaucoup
d'attendre là-dessus et et en fait
encore une fois oui on a cette démarche
là elle est honorable mais c'est pas à
la phage de permettre un accès un
thérapeute à tous les étudiants
étudiants de toute la France parce que
déjà concrètement on pourra pas le faire
et en fait on est juste des étudants
étudiantes qui s'engagent et et c'est
pour ça qu'en fait on on demande au
servicees publics de prendre ces
responsabilités là parce que c'est la
l'heure c'est celle de leur public de
leur futur citoyens citoyennes et des
futures personnes actives dans la
société al j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
initiative intéressante à l'université
de de Bordeaux qui s'est mise en place
c'est une formation au premier soin au
secours en santé mentale
euh qu'on a qui ont été mis en place
donc sur le le campus de de Bordeaux euh
960 étudiants en 2022 auraient été
formés à ses premiers
soins pour Pier au à la détérioration de
la santé mentale des des étudiants ce
genre d'initiative j'imagine que on ne
peut que les encourager ou alors sont
encore des béquilles selon vous moi je
pense que c'est très important comme la
pédans les premiers soins en santé
mentale mais ça ne doit pas venir euh à
la place du de
renforcer les les soins psychiques et et
les soins au potentiellement au long
cours pour les étudiants c'està-dire que
la tendance actuelle c'est quand même
plutôt de soutenir toutes ces actions
qui sont très intéressantes très
importantes mais c'est du court terme et
en fait les services de de de santé
mentale qui peuvent voilà qui existent
sont sont peu soutenus voire pas
soutenus on va en venir aux solutions on
va essayer de positiver un tout petit
peu hein parce que c'est vrai que après
ce documentaire euh bon on se dit que
c'est c'est difficile c'est très
compliqué pour cette pour cette
génération euh quelle solution vous vous
mîriz en avant quelle solution
proposez-vous à ceux et celles qui qui
qui arrivent justement à faire cette
démarche allez vous voir et et à
demander conseils et à être suivi sur un
plan psychologique quelles sont les
premières choses que vous que vous
pouvez essayer de mettre en place avec
ceux et celles qui sont en détresse
psychologique euh votre question c'est
sur les les du coup les étudiants qui
qui s'adresse au service de oui ou qui
s'adresse à des psychologues ou voilà
qu'est-ce que bon il y a il y a il y a
une analyse il y a un diagnostic mais il
y a aussi sans doute des chemins à
prendre pour que les choses aillent
mieux quels sont les chemins à prendre
pour que les choses aillent mieux vous
préconisezutre ouis peut-être sur le
parcours effectivement alors il y a tous
les services d'écoute les les premiers
secours en santémental qui sont
importants après il y a le service de
soins de santé universitaire où il y a
des psychologues mais souvent c'est des
prises en charge limité dans le temps
quelques mois et après avec des fils
d'attente on l'a dit juste avant hein
qui sont considérables considérablesou
et après quand c'est des choses qu' on
besoin de de soins plus longs euh donc
il y a les bureaux d'aide psychologiques
universitaires qui malheureusement sont
pas assez développés et répandus mais
euh voilà là c'est des des équipes avec
des psychiatres des psychologues il y a
des groupes de la relaxation enfin on
peut proposer plusieurs choses donc ça
dépend un peu du du besoin de l'étudiant
en fait parce que entre la détresse
psychologique et l'entrée dans une
maladie psychiatrique les réponses sont
différentes en fait en fonction des des
besoins des étudiants il faut que la
parole se libère c'était ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure elle se libère
auprès de qui la parole est-ce qu'elle
doit pas se libérer en premier auprès
des parents des frères des sœurs de de
ceux qui qui connaissent bien votre
situation à qui en tout cas vous pouvez
peut-être en parler des amis très
proches euh qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
moi je pense qu' tout ça c'est fondé sur
un manque d'information et donc il faut
réellement euh aider bah oui les person
personnes qui nous entourent les parents
les proches les personnes qui qui sont
pas forcément elles-mêm touchées par la
santé mentale mais qui ont mais qui sont
touché indirectement à travers nous à
travers leurs enfants à travers leurs
proches et donc il faut les aider à
avoir plus d'outils pour épauler ces
personnes face à leurs problèmes et et
pouvoir essayer de de justement voilà de
lever la parole et de parler ouvertement
de ces problèmes encourager les jeunes à
parler ouvertement de de leurs problèmes
en fait vous disiez la santé mentale des
jeunes finalement c'est encore un sujet
tabou et il faut que la parole c'est
exprime c'est un sujet tabou pour qui
pour les parents par exemple qui sont
sans doute les premiers concernés qui
s'intéressent à priori un tempant soit
peu à l'avenir de leur prjéniture ils
sont pas sensibilisés à ce problème
c'est c'est pour eux c'est c'est c'est
quelque chose qu'ils ont peut-être du
mal à percevoir et et de fait leurs
enfants ont du mal à leur en parler
est-ce que vous ressentez les choses
comme ça
ouais je pense qu'aujourd'hui notre
génération à nous elle est assez ouverte
sur le sujet quand même et donc ce tabou
il est principalement fondé autour des
générations précédentes donc nos parents
et tout ça et euh c'est vrai que je
pense qu'ils ont du mal à comprendre
parce que ils se disent que c'est
quelque chose comme je disais avant qui
est assez normalisé en fait à notre âge
et et donc ils ont ils ont beaucoup de
mal à à à comprendre que que ça peut
être des souffrances plus profonde que
un simple stress face à un examen ou ou
quelque chose comme ça et donc et donc
nous on veut montrer que c'est ces
problèmes de santé mental ils arrivent à
tout le monde et que c'est quelque chose
c'est pas quelque chose de dramatique en
soi et mais mais c'est pas non plus
quelque chose de normal donc donc il
faut essayer de trouver cet entre deux
pour pouvoir bien accompagner les
personnes souffrantes de santé mentale
et je trouve que le premier secours en
santé mentale c'est une formation et en
fait c'est un peu cette idée là c'est
cette idée de libérer la parole et nous
à la fche ce qu'on souhaiterait c'est
que l'ensemble du corps enseignant à
l'université et tes les personnes qui
sont en contact avec des é v il faut
parler des enseignants il en a entendu
et ben en fait il faut que ell et eux
soient sensibilisé à cette thématique là
parce qu'enit quand on sait que
actuellement nous on en parle beaucoup
dans notre génération mais c'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui se faisait
beaucoup avant et B l'idée de de former
au maximum à cette à cette formation de
premier secours l'idée c'est pas de
remplacer un thérapeute au contraire
l'idée c'est de rappeler en fait que
avoir un trouble de santé mentale et
quelqu'un qui a un trouble de santé
mentale peut être dans une situation de
détresse aussi grande que quelqu'un qui
a un problème de santé qui est qui est
urgent et donc en fait sensibiliser à ça
et sensibilisé au fait en fait qu'il y a
des acteurs et actrices vers qui on peut
se tourner en cas d'une santé mentale
dégradée et donc c'est un peu l'idée
derrière derrière le premier secours en
santé mental et on parlait de solution
nous les solutions qu'on voit c'est déjà
investir au maximum le dispositif santé
PSI étudiant le faire durer dans le
temps lever ce cette limite de 8 Séan on
a pu le dire et aussi de manière
générale quand on parle d'accès à la
santé des étudiants étudiantes le
meilleur moyen de le lever c'est c'est
le enfin permettre un tiers payant donc
le fait que les étuds ne payent pas et
enfin on l'a vu si on a une santé
mentale dégradée c'est par des causes
c'est un contexte qu'il fait donc là on
a parlé plutôt du du curatif du
thérapeutique donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant dans l'urgence mais
actuellement pour éviter et pour
empêcher que d'autres étudi retrouve
dans cette détresse psychologique le
meilleur moyen d'agir c'est d'agir sur
la précarité étudiante et la précarité
financière et on l'a vu avec la réforme
des bourses il a un jeune dans ce
documentaire qui dit bon j'étais pas
préparé à être lancé dans le grand main
et le grand main c'est quoi c'est
l'accès à la vie professionnelle il nous
reste très peu de temps ça c'est
l'angoisse
majeure l'entrée dans la vie
professionnelle oui mais aussi je pense
la vie affective enfin je
pense effectivement la vie
professionnelle mais mais tous les les
axes de la vie en fait je crois il y a
des formules tout de même dans
l'enseignement secondaire on pense à
l'alternance l'apprentissage qui peut
s'adresser aux jeunes directement
d'ailleurs après la les études
secondaires qui permettent de graduer de
avec une avancée progressive dans ce
fameux milieu du travail dans cette
jungle du travail qui peut faire peur
effectivement
euh qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
est-ce qu'il faut en passer par ces
trajets là ces trajectoires là ces
cursus là de de de formation pour un
temps soit peut aussi alléger la santé
mentale de quelques jeunes pour nous
c'est quelque chose qu'on dénonce
justement de pousser les gens vers le
projet professionnel parce qu'en fait
l'enseignement SP ceci un moment où on
s'émancipe on s'émancipe de la condition
de vie dans laquelle on est et en fait
on a un peu cette volonté de se nourrir
avec nos études parce qu'on façonne les
citoyens citoyennes de demain et donc
avoir cette idée de directement
réfléchir à l'université sur quels sont
les les les besoins au niveau des
entreprises quels sont les besoins au
niveau professionnel et donc on va
former des étudants étudiantes là
actuellement on s'en rend compte les
places de licence elles sont master il y
en a qui se ferment uniquement pour
répondre à un besoin euh de de de de
monde de l'entreprise et en fait on
rentre dans une une question de
privatisation de l'enseignement
supérieur de de de de d'économie aussi
d'argent qu'on investit et là je pense
qu'on a fait le constat que on a du mal
à se projeter dans la société on a aussi
juste du mal à se projeter dans
l'université et dans la pression qu'on
nous impose et donc la coursese à
l'alternance la la course au stage la
course à avoir un projet de
professionnel défini tout de suite
maintenant ça aussi ça va ça engendre
une une période de stress et la période
de 20 ans c'est l'âge de tous les
possibles parce que justement on peut se
projeter là où on veut et on peut faire
le projet professionnel qu'on veut et
actuellement ça l'IT pas et donc pousser
l'université vers cette alternance là
vers le fait d'aller encore plus vers
une vision professionnelle ça va juste
aller aggraver encore plus ces déstess
psychologique et cette pression qui
existe au sein de l'université donc nous
à la fche pour nous c'est beaucoup plus
un danger qu'une solution au contraire
ouais je pense qu'il faut se se se
détacher de ce côté des études qui est
aussi très élitiste dans un sens parce
qu'en fait aujourd'hui on nous demande
plus de réussir seulement mais on nous
demande d'exceller en fait face face à
au manque de place dans l'enseignement
supérieur donc je pense que en fait je
suis pas experte en santé mentale mais
je sais que la santé mentale est basée
sur des facteurs de risque donc dont on
parlait et les facteurs de protection et
il faut que pour trouver des solutions
individuellement face à nos problèmes de
santé mental aussi il faut essayer de
développer des facteurs de protection
donc chacun développe des petites choses
moi par exemple mon engagement inicef il
m'a beaucoup aidé parce que on a on a
beaucoup parler entre jeunes de la santé
mentale tout ça euh juste faire des
petites activités au quotidien qui nous
donne du plaisir c'est des c'est des
facteurs de protection qui nous aident à
à à aller de l'avant et à se se détacher
un petit peu de ce côté très très très
éitiste des études et de toute cette
pression ça sera le mot de la fin merci
vraiment à toutes les trois he d'avoir
participer à à ce débat dog qu'on a
consacré à la santé mentale fragilisé
aujourd'hui hein du côté des de ceux qui
ont 20 ans vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtagdbadog merci à sel Mali qui m'a
aidé comme elle accoutumé à présenter
cette émission je vous donne rendez-vous
bien entendu pour un prochain débat dooc
et ça sera bien entendu avec son
documentaire et son débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt